olivier tricon travaille depuis plus de
30 ans avec le japon une bouteille sur
quatre produits dans son domaine est
exportée au pays du soleil levant avec
la suppression des droits de douane
il espère en profiter pour grignoter des
parts de marché
je crois que c'est très important pour
reconquérir des marchés
on avait pris énormément de retard
depuis une dizaine d'années face aux
concurrents dans le vin sud-américain
chili argentine quand beaucoup moins de
contraintes administratives et de
production que nous cet accord j'espère
pour un nous repositionner encore mieux
sur le sur le japon en l'occurrence le
japon représente le troisième marché
d'exportation pour le chablis derrière
le royaume uni premier importateur
mais face à l'impact économique lié aux
briques site les viticulteurs doivent se
résoudre à trouver d'autres relais de
croissance
c'est forcément une source d'inquiétude
car le royaume uni reste notre première
destination à l'export une façon très
significative et donc effectivement de
fait nous devons imaginer un
repositionnement et c'est vrai que cette
négociation avec le japon qui nous est
favorable à mon sens est de ce point de
vue elle très bonne nouvelle
conséquence de ce nouvel accord le
consommateur japonais pourra profiter du
chablis un meilleur tarif
de quoi espérer pour les viticulteurs y
connaît une augmentation significative
des ventes dans l'immédiat l'effet n'est
pas encore ressenti mais je pense que ce
sera clairement une amélioration pour
les relations avec les les importateurs
japonais avec un à d'excellentes
relations content c'est pas nouveau mais
ça doivent encore plus facilité je pense
les échanges commerciaux avec ce nouvel
accord les producteurs de chaabi espère
accroître leur place sur le marché
asiatique
les vins du chablisien représente
aujourd'hui 27% des vins de bourgogne
exportés vers le japon